we're going to have a look today at a
proof by contradiction
uh proofs by contradictions are pretty
weird because we're working with
negations
and unlike where we're used to thinking
of things as proving you know something
to be true
we're actually trying to go in the
opposite direction so logically there's
a little bit of acrobatics and
gymnastics
involved but if you know how to state
things clearly using all the
mathematical knowledge and skill that
you've accrued over the last
you know 11 to 12 years you should be
able to prove things by contradiction
sometimes
much more easily than by direct proof so
let's dive into this question
and see if we can make heads or tails of
it question 10 part a says
explain why every odd number is one more
or one less than a multiple of four okay
let's
start to unpack this uh to start with
part a
if we want to say that every odd number
is one more
or one less than a multiple of four then
i guess what we're trying to say
is um all the numbers that are one more
than a multiple of four
they sort of make up a sequence of
numbers and all the numbers that are one
less
than a multiple of four they make up
another sequence of numbers and if we
combine those two two sequences together
then what this
first thing is saying is we should
capture every single odd number so how
can we
explain that well we can do it without
too much trouble if we say for instance
let's uh introduce some sequence of
numbers
a sub n and let's define them as the
ones that are all one less
than a multiple of four so a multiple of
four would be of the form
for n and one less than that would be
four n
minus one where n is some integer
okay so if we think of all of the
numbers of this form again we're trying
to do in part a it says explain so this
is not quite so
formal what i'm going to do is think
about well what's the first
set of numbers or what's the first
sequence of numbers that i get out of
this right
well this implies that you know a1
a2 a3 they're gonna be something like
well i guess you know four take away one
and then
eight take away one this is me
incrementing up
for the integer values of n and the next
one be 12 minus 1
and so on i should have said this
sequence does go on forever dot dot dot
so the numbers we're getting out of this
the numbers that we're generating are
3 7 11 and so
on if we then think about all those
numbers that are one
more than a multiple of four that's a
whole different
sequence so i can also say let b
sub n lets that make the ones that are
bigger i've already introduced n
as an integer so i don't need to say
anything further what that implies is
that the way this sequence begins
b1 b2 b3
uh what would be the value of n that
would give me
the first you know when we think about
multiples we tend to think even though
you know positive negatives are fine we
tend to think about the natural numbers
so i guess we would want uh zero plus
one that's the
zeroth multiple of four and then we
would go four plus one
and then a plus one those multiples of
sort four that we saw earlier
so that gives us one and then five and
then
nine dot dot dot but we can then say
well these are the two sequences we
started with the four n minus ones and
the four and plus ones
if we compare that you can see it's
already starting to fall apart here
right
or fall together maybe i can say but
the odd numbers this is i i want every
odd number to be included here
the odd numbers i guess i would call
them o
of n um the way that you would say them
is they're 2n
minus 1. they're not based on multiples
of 4 they're based on multiples of 2.
they're all the even numbers take away
1. so
that implies again i'm now trying to um
put this all together in one neat bow
the first three odd numbers dot dot dot
uh in fact i could do more than that i
mean you can see i've got 1 3
5 7 9 11 and so on
which you can see perfectly lining up
with the numbers we already have there's
three seven
eleven three seven eleven and then
here's
one five and nine so you can see i
haven't missed out any
and i could just continue this pattern
uh forever so
what i can say here is therefore every
odd number because i've captured
everything in this
o sub n series every odd number
can be written as
either 4n minus 1 or 4n
plus 1 and i have a single piece of
notation which combines both of those
together
so i can say 4n plus or minus
1. and what that implies is that
every odd number is either
one more or one less
than a multiple of four
all right so i'm pretty happy with that
explanation and i hope you're
convinced as well so and we'll start
there and see how part a leads onto the
rest of the question scrolling back up
prove that the product of any two
positive integers of the form
four n plus one that seems seems pretty
important and we we saw we used this
from earlier on
uh when talking about this four n plus
one these are all of the numbers one
more than a multiple of four
prove that the product of any two
positive integers that look like this
where n's a positive integer is also of
the form
four n plus one so what are we saying
here what we're suggesting is
if you've got two numbers that are both
one more than a multiple of four then if
you multiply them together you get
another number that is also
one more than a multiple of four so we
can quickly verify this right
um here here was our sequence here one
five nine which has our
numbers that are one more than a
multiple of four so if we took
say uh i've only got two uh you know
interesting ones here
if i said you know say five times nine
this is me multiplying
two numbers in this four n plus one
format what do i get well
4 5 times 9 is 45 and that indeed is
1 more than a multiple of 4. so
this is just an example of what i'm
trying to do
but i don't want to just prove this with
an example i need to do this in a
logical way that captures
every possible case so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to
rather look at some specific versions of
4 and plus 1
i need to think about this in general
terms so i need to introduce
this 4n plus 1 and that 4n plus 1.
that's already immediately confusing
because i'm using
n in two senses there so let's introduce
some new prenumerals so we can
distinguish these two
versions of 4n plus 1 by saying for
different values of n
so let's uh let
uh p and q that'll be a couple of
letters that can stand in for us
let's let them be our our ends in this
case so that means they both have to be
positive integers as question b
specifies
so therefore the multiples of four plus
one
that go with this are going to be of the
form let's consider
four p plus one and four q
plus 1. so here's the first version of 4
n plus 1 and here's some other
4 n plus 1. we tried out 5 and 9 in our
previous example just to convince
ourselves that it worked
let's just expand this right so what am
i going to get
and 16pq i get to get 4p plus 4q
and then the last terms just give me one
right now what am i trying to get to
well i'm trying to show as i did over
here
that i've got a plus one over here and
then everything else is a multiple of 4.
well that's not too complicated to see
because
if you have a look at these terms here
i can factorize out that 4. in fact
that's exactly what i'm going to do
put the 4 out there put some brackets
here what do i get left with
4pq plus p
plus q let's close our bracket and that
plus 1 is already conveniently just
sitting there so
what have i got here this is of the form
4n
plus 1. this is let's introduce a new
letter for
r plus one so this is a specific n
where you can see here because r
which is this piece in here it's made up
of uh
integers being multiplied and added
together so when you
add and multiply integers you just get
more integers so i can say this r is
also
not just an integer it's a positive
integer because
p and q as you multiply them together
because they started with positive so
you're never going to go into negatives
here
you're just making numbers bigger and
bigger okay
so this is it right that's kind of what
i needed
when you multiply two numbers that are
in this 4n plus 1 format you get another
number in 4n plus 1 format